[Musique]
c'est dimanche dernier que le chanteur m
pokora a eu la bonne surprise d'être
désigné meilleur artiste français 2020
aux mtv europe music awards
une récompense prestigieuse qui a mis en
joie le jeune homme merci du fond du
coeur pour ce trophée c'est la première
fois je sais que vous avez voté comme
des fous alors merci du fond du coeur
une belle nouvelle qui a très vite été
nuancé par le message d'ayem nakamura
en effet la chanteuse qui cartonne a eu
un peu plus de mal à avaler la pilule
pour elle m pokora ne mérite pas cette
distinction il a gagné pour qu'elles
sont rien contre lui mais il est même
pas dans le top 10 de son côté le
chanteur matt houston son ennemi juré
qu'ils avaient notamment attaqué m
pokora pour l'empêcher de se faire
appeler maths on a lui aussi rajouter
une couche
s'il a d'abord posté le message diana
camorra il a ensuite commenté
il n'y a rien à effacer lui c'est une
comment ce film gagne tout le temps sans
avoir fait que dalle
c'est nous on vous fait danser c'est
nous la culture respecter un peu dure a
pas de prochain johnny ici un clash qui
risque de laisser des traces
alors moi je veux parler à tuer parce
que maty vraiment mon ami et je l'aimais
vraiment matt pokora et il a toujours
été avec moi il m'a jamais lâché c'est
un mec d'une fidélité incroyable et
j'aime ma tu vois là et puis là rien dit
c'est ouais ça y est pourquoi en fait à
mon avis il est ville match houston et
il a une genre lyria nakamura qui
l'attaqué aussi oui aussi mais en même
temps c'était le vote du public un pâle
à l'aplomb du rhin millions de kwh en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya
quelques années
matthew stone est parti voir la maison
de disques en demandant il fallait
absolument que matt pokora change de nom
et c'est pour ça qu'il est passé de matt
pokora à m pokora et oui il a dû signer
un papier sinon il y avait procès
celui-ci non son album ne sortait pas et
ensuite quand il était chez mouloud
achour
matt pokora a dit quand il a ressorti
cette affaire en attendant moi je suis
toujours la balle est donc là il m'a
fait mettre automne et voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui il est ville des mois sur
cette affaire il ya une personne que
j'ai envie d'entendre
c'est quand même le spécialiste du rnb
en français rené malleville vraiment
voilà si elle personne qu'on veut en
voir entendre là dessus c'est comme ça
me
fichier qui parle comme ça des m pokora
parce que m pokora
j'ai une anecdote avec lui moi je suis
sur nos radios à marseille qui s'appelle
radio star mais un jour on l'avait
unités comme indiqué et les venues de
voir qu'on avait déjà recommandé de voir
arriver il se met à genoux devant moi et
je suis fan de toi et l'arrivée des
invités à vous yma tout le monde a été
choqué moi le premier est de pire en
état mais c'est un amour de ma vie je
comprends qu'ils soient fans de vous
parce que c'est ce que je vous ai dit
vous moi aussi j'étais fan de journée
c'est vrai c'est oui oui kelly un peu
l'histoire
j'ai trouvé un haka mourra modéré et
peut-être un petit peu légitime dans son
tweet ya rien de méchant n'y a pas d'
insulte pour canal plus marco chorale se
ressent elle et lui ça se trouve même
lui même la comprend dans le tudca l'ami
très mature stone je trouve vraiment
mauvais ils feraient mieux de sortir des
singles comme il en a fait des très bien
avant me réhabitue se remettre à la
musique on va donc non plus un très bon
artiste malien insulter les gens public
mais matt pokora qui s'émerveillent de
la libye
on dira ce qu'on voudra m pokora ça fait
15 ans toute une carrière etc
bravo à lui c'est des rageux les autres
même on a été très gentil avec il ya la
camorra on a fait son tweet elle est
capable de faire une faute d'orthographe
en quatre mots enfin bref
j'vais 5 twh en 3d quand ici surtout
bassim sa porte encore à l insulte
jamais personne fait son job il fait
dans la spectaculaire avec son public c
est les autres
ce qui désole me pense qu'elle a perdu
vous avez été sur de nombreuses
émissions de variétés mine de rien
france télévisions vous en avez lancé
plein est ce qu'une guerre entre les
artistes excuse s'entendent bien le
monde de la réalité de mon de la chanson
bien ce que c'est la guerre entre 10h et
un peu comme la télévision tout le monde
s'entend vachement bien non elle est là
les lensois tentent pas c'est toujours
compliqué de faire une émission par
exemple d'humour
est ce que en règle générale il ya
toujours trop quatre familles
différentes
mais les gens jouent le jeu en tout cas
ils sont respectueux là ce qu'on voit
c'est que les gens sont de moins en
moins respectueux comment on peut
remettre un prix du public comment on
peut le remettre en cause et comment on
peut assumer tes rien demandé enfin je
veux dire maintenant on critique tous et
ont commencé à insulter tout le monde
donc il y ferait que sassari nord les
[ __ ] ils s'aiment pas entre eux
aussi jouent le jeu ils ont je vous dise
ballon balancé un truc aux
téléspectateurs et bonjour je m'en fous
et à prendre des risques il dit nicolas
et je sais que vous c'est vos potes
sachez que les télétubbies se détestent
s'il faut dire les choses voilà jeudi